we just had historical polling failure
the the
the worst ever seven percent exactly was
the failure rate
yeah and now you've got people tweeting
things like you're projecting joe biden
one before certification
and you're also the ones who got the
entire polling wrong of course they're
lumping the media together of course
uh the the the the various polling
institutions all were pulling ridiculous
numbers against trump
the race is extremely close and the
media runs
full speed like wikipedia has already
put up on the president-elect page
a picture of joe biden which is like
wait wait
president elect as a concept doesn't
need a picture of anybody
well let me put joe biden but let's be
clear about something when trump won in
2016
the media called it for him within
a few hours is around 3 a.m i think the
the following day so i mean this is not
really that different and there was
still a lot of uncertainty
at least among despondent liberals as to
the legitimacy the legitimacy of the
election
there are people demanding recounts in
wisconsin pennsylvania michigan
some of which did happen at the behest
of jill stein which was
hilarious because she made millions and
millions of dollars
mostly from hillary clinton supporters
because i don't think
that most green party supporters should
they said that they they even exist or
not deep pocketed
so i mean there's nothing unusual when
you're like when the people now say the
media called
the election i mean that happens every
election that happened when trump won
right the votes weren't certified the
the states didn't certify the results in
2016 until weeks after
i'm not i'm not uh i'm not claiming that
trump
is uh well let me put it this way yeah
when when when the media said trump wins
trump was like i won
and now the media is like joe biden's
like no he didn't right but it's a
formal that's why i keep going to let's
at least
strive to have some logical consistency
in how we see the world i mean that's
one of my baseline desires so
but the issue is the media calling it
it's a formality hillary clinton that's
that's an in
the formality is when the states certify
the results i no no
no the the for you can't you can't be
saying that the media decides who the
president is
well you said the media calling is a
formality it's like an informality it's
when they're able to make a projection
they call it
and it's not formalized until the states
certify the results
what i mean is uh to clarify when the
media calls it it's just more of a
tradition
that the media says we've projected the
numbers here's our winner and then
typically you have results where it's
like all right all right all right
i'm out and the campaigns look at their
numbers they look at you know edison
research or
ap and say we see what the numbers are
this one was an extremely close race and
i will say the difference between
hillary clinton conceding within a
couple days
is that we didn't have the results he
conceded the next day but we didn't have
the results until saturday
so trump was up he couldn't concede you
know that's right no i think i think so
it would have been ridiculous i mean i
think nobody would have expected
biden would have had to conceded at that
point yeah until until at least you know
it was quote called
um but
it is a little bit of a rewriting of
history though to say that it's just the
media calling it i know that
conservatives really absolutely
fox news but like they are you know they
were they were they
they all did it simultaneously you know
so you know unless you're saying that
was last i think but real clear politics
hasn't called it
well i mean does real clear does real
clear politics have its own
tracking system it does proprietary vote
counting mechanism like the associated
press or fox
i don't know about that i know that they
have just like uh
i think most of these outlets use the ap
or whatever right so they're not
making calls they're just tracking ap's
numbers but rcp has
their map not all of them i mean the
reason the fox called it called arizona
um fox called arizona first yeah and ap
did it a few hours later so they're
using they're using different systems
and they they all did it pretty much
simultaneously on saturday morning
because that's when a certain
a batch of philadelphia votes came in
that rendered it
they say impossible for trump to make up
the margin at least you know
leaving aside any kind of fraud
allegations so there was an article from
july written by the co-founder of msnbc
that many people called
anti they called it anti-trump
resistance porn
like it was one of these articles that
were like trump is a dictator
and they said it was called how trump
can lose the election
and still win the presidency and they
said what would happen is
there's four states wisconsin michigan
arizona and pennsylvania that have
republican legislatures
they're swing states they'll the
argument was
they'll go for biden but trump will make
some accusation about national security
or fraud
thus locking up the certification
process until the deadline
when the supreme court will then say if
we don't have the electoral college
certified
by the 14th then it goes to house
delegations and the house delegations
are republican
they would re-elect donald trump that's
what this guy was warning of
now i think all of these arguments trump
invalidating votes or whatever
uh house delegation are long shots
but i'm looking at you know trump
getting rid so trump's getting rid of
the pentagon
you know leadership maybe he's just on
the way out he's just saying i'm going
to get rid of all these people whatever
he's mad
or we heard that he instructed the uh
the federal agencies to produce their
budgets for february as if he wasn't
leaving
then we had mike pompeo secretary of
state saying there will be a smooth
transition
to a second trump administration and
then i think he chuckled which people
were saying that that many wasn't meant
to be 100 serious but then again who
knows but then but then it was announced
that trump is telling federal agencies
keep the budgets like don't change
anything you're doing
so yeah what was what yeah again like i
mentioned before georgia is also a
republican state legislature so
that would be will be a similar scenario
potentially
you know i think i think it was
interesting um
what was said yesterday by bill barr
when he put out a memo authorizing
certain investigations and that
that's unprecedented right uh i believe
so but maybe there was but the way that
he worded it was very interesting
because bill barr if nothing else
is very astute at knowing how to like
almost manage
trump because so much of what trump has
demanded
vis-a-vis like the durham investigation
into the origins of russia gate
or various other justice department
initiatives
billboard really hasn't delivered fully
on
and there were even reports about how
annoyed trump apparently was with barr
in the past few weeks
and i think there's sort of a
continuation of that theme here because
if you actually read the memo that he
that barr put out that was reported
he said that it is equally no not with
santa that he authorized these
preliminary investigations
he said it is equally imperative that
department personnel exercise
appropriate caution and maintain oh
sorry not that he said that while
serious
allegations should be handled with great
care specious
speculative fanciful or far-fetched
claims should not be a basis for
initiating federal inquiries
so why would he even include that
proviso if not
as a kind of quasi-rebuttal of apparent
allegations that he apparently believes
don't have merit you know so he's like
treading a line here
where i think he's just trying to to
some extent play kate
trump and but also maintain
some boring and the reality is he sees
the election
going in terms of the final outcome when
they called the results on saturday
i'm just thinking it's going to be
another boring
you know trump's finally going to be
like all right you know he's gonna
throw a fit in some capacity and then i
thought we'd move on but he's not
and then for a while i thought you know
at least for a couple days or like a day
or two because it's only what tuesday
i was like okay trump's probably just
gonna you know drag it out we're seeing
reports that he's like selling his
helicopter
i don't know if that's true though
because it's hard it's hard to know what
to trust anymore when you see these
stories that come out
you know and and this is like normally i
i trust for the most part these
organizations i fact check them
but i can't fact check these claims that
trump sells his helicopter i can't go to
a website and look up the sale of a
helicopter
so i don't know if he's actually selling
this stuff but then we saw a story from
cbs that
trump's fundraising for election recount
60 first goes to paying off campaign
debt
right i heard keith olbermann say that i
went to his fundraising site it wasn't
there
i mean i get those solicitations did you
see them saying if you look at the
if you look at the small text there is
something
that references that so what i saw it
said 60
will go to save america i don't know if
it was 60 but there
but there is there is a provision in
there that which says that some of this
could be used to retire
uh campaign debt i mean i think that i
don't and i felt this
across the board for the democratic
campaigns and republican campaigns
don't bother giving them money at this
point i mean the consultants
are just drowning in cash at this point
it's
ridiculous jamie harrison the senate
democratic candidate in south carolina
raised the most
money for any senate race ever and lost
and lost and it was in south carolina
which is like not a big media market
and at los angeles like charleston it's
not like he had to run
in california yeah right so all you're
doing when you
go to your act blue donation page which
is how so many of these democratic
candidates get their contributions
is you're lining the pockets of
consultants who don't have to even
deliver on any of their promises in
order to make
the money that they're going to make i
mean they probably are all buying
tesla's now because you thought jamie
harrison had a legitimate
chance of beating lindsey graham in
south carolina and graham won by double
digits didn't he
yeah i think it was the 13 points or
something totally crushed him and like
likewise i mean
look if you're a die-hard trump
supporter and you want to pull out all
the stops do everything possible legally
to certify
to prevent the certification of the
votes before we're 100 sure that it's
complete okay fine but like just know
that you're paying the salaries of
lawyers
and consultants if you're clicking on
the solicitations and giving money
and they don't even need your money at
this point they have plenty of money
yeah they're just doing it because they
can because they want because they have
those email lists that are
these you know boondoggles that you know
they could
squeeze every last drop thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you